let's talk politics early voting is
already underway and we're a little more
than two weeks away from the primary
election in nevada coming up quick here
in nevada early voting taking place all
across town and today henderson
residents are going to be able to cast
their early votes as well we joined mary
jane bellies this morning to give us a
little more information good morning
heather good morning to you this is the
first year that every nevada voter will
get a ballot in the mail and locations
like this one at desert breeze park will
remain open through june 10th henderson
residents can vote early in person
starting this morning through june 9th
from 7 30 a.m to 5 30 p.m north las
vegas residents were also able to vote
early this past weekend they can submit
their ballots for city mayor city
council wards 1-3 and municipal court
judge departments 1-2 make sure you sign
the outside of your envelope provided
specifically for you before mailing your
ballot out or dropping it in a dropbox
there were a steady amount of voters who
also turned up at desert breeze park to
vote
i think that the early voting is the way
we're going now with
i mean it's going to be pretty much
over by june june 10th
these two weeks and the mail boating you
know the formality is just a formality
when the june 14th of election day comes
around
as a reminder do not put your ballot in
another voters return envelope and for a
full list of candidates and voting
locations just head to our website at
eight newsnow dot com for that full list
reporting live from cimarron and spring
mountain mary jane ballaza live local
now